one of the best things about special
features on DVDs and Blu-rays is the
Litany of deleted scenes but sometimes
omitting those scenes creates pesky plot
holes that would have been sealed If
Only They had just stayed in place here
are some deleted scenes that would have
fixed some of Cinema's most pesky and
confusing plot points aliens aliens is
one of the best movies ever made but it
does have one weird issue it seems like
Ripley is barely affected by anything
she goes through the whole movie showing
about two emotions kill and kill with
fire
but that's a little weird right after
all she comes back after a hundred years
of sleep her whole family and life have
passed away and she basically shrugs it
all off it just seems like she's being a
little too Cavalier about it all but
that wouldn't be the case if this
deleted scene was left in we see here
that her daughter's death of old age
really did have a profound effect on her
in addition to making Ripley not seem
like you know a robot it also makes her
bond with nude at the end of the movie
make a ton more sense she's trying to
replace the daughter-sized hole in her
heart
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows if
you've only ever seen the two Deathly
Hallows films and never read the books
you probably think it's weird that the
Death Eaters managed to always find Ron
Harry and Hermione were they wearing
some kind of tracking Beacon did they
forget to turn the GPS on their wands
off what the heck well the actual reason
is simple Voldemort put a curse on his
own name so that whenever anyone says it
he and the Death Eaters can detect them
and find them which isn't a problem for
most people because they all call them
you know who but then there's Harry who
refuses to so every time he says
Voldemort's name in an attempt to puff
up his chest and say I'm not scared of
him he's actually shining a huge
Spotlight for all the guys who want to
kill him of course eventually he learns
better because Ron tells him
that's how they track people now how do
you know that I've heard some bloke at
the ministry's talking about it but the
filmmakers deleted that scene so it
suddenly goes from Death Eaters knowing
where Harry and the Gang are 24 7 to
them never knowing it's not the worst
plot hole in the whole series but that
scene probably could have cleared up a
whole lot of confusion the Lord of the
Rings The Lord of the Rings is one of
the best trilogies ever but there's
always been one weird part in it Boromir
he alternates between heroism and
villainy seemingly at random it all
comes to a head when Boromir tries to
take the ring from Frodo at Amon Hen
most of us assume that the Ring's
influence corrupted Boromir but there's
a much sadder explanation as revealed in
one of the deleted scenes that made its
way into the extended editions as we
know from Return of the King boromir's
father denethor is a cruel unforgiving
man he's the guy who sends Boromir to
the council to claim the one ring to
bring glory to Gondor
so when Boromir seems lustful over the
ring he's really just trying to be a
good son to please his overbearing prick
of a father I trust this Mission only to
your brother
the one who will not fail me
guys a total butt face this also means
his dad has been one of the most
destructive forces in the entire Saga
since the first movie seriously this guy
is worse than Saruman Groundhog Day
Groundhog Day easily ranks up there with
Bill Murray's best films Murray's
character relives one day in his life
for seemingly no purpose over and over
then put your little hand in mine
[Music]
due to the lack of explanation in the
finished film people have argued for
years about just what the heck the point
of it all is and while some might argue
that it's actually one of the movie's
high points that doesn't make the
explanations absence any less confusing
what's making Murray so Death Proof
he might be okay
while still in development the
filmmakers had a simple and kind of dumb
explanation in mind an ex of Murray's
character cursed him until he could
learn how to actually love at which
point the curse would end fortunately
this scene was cut before it was even
filmed because honestly a clear-cut
explanation like that would have just
taken away from what makes the movie so
great in the first place
Connors Ned
Star Trek if you don't remember who Nero
is we'll catch you up he's the Romulan
bald bad guy in JJ Abrams 2009 reboot of
Star Trek who screams fire everything
he's also the one who kills Captain
Kirk's dad Thor while Kirk is too busy
being born to save him but after the
opening scene Nero just conveniently
disappears until Kirk's all grown up
what was he doing taking a vacation
actually he was being held prisoner off
in deleted scenes land the film needed
about 20 years to pass so that Nero
could face off against an adult Captain
Kirk so JJ Abrams and Company had to
give him something to do in the meantime
their idea was that Nero was captured by
Klingons and held prisoner for years
until he could finally break free listen
to the voice of everybody's favorite
Star Trek character Exposition man it's
been more than 20 years era since we
captured your ship the filmmakers
ultimately cut this scene out of the
movie leaving a big gaping question mark
in the plot that no amount of lens
flares could cover up
Return of the Jedi one of the biggest
questions in Return of the Jedi has
annoyed fans for years why didn't
Obi-Wan just tell Luke that Darth Vader
was his father in the first place he
started out as a pretty cool old guy
showing him fancy laser swords in his
creepy desert Hut but then he straight
up lied to Luke about who his father
really was well guess what turns out it
wasn't Obi-Wan's fault it was Yoda who
confessed the truth on his deathbed
here's how the final cut of that scene
went not ready for the burger for you
I'm sorry but the original version had
an extra line that took all the blame
off Obi-Wan
ready for the burden were you
[Music]
Obi-Wan would have told you long ago had
I let him Yoda purposefully kept the
secret from Luke even forbidding Obi-Wan
from telling Luke out of fear what Luke
would do if he knew the truth and while
we're on the subject of confusing Jedi
dad issues this one's a doozy
Revenge of the Sith in The Phantom
Menace we find out that Anakin has no
father but that's a little silly even
Jesus had a dad so who was Anakin's The
Phantom Menace never tells us but a
deleted scene from Revenge of the Sith
reveals the truth the scene which George
Lucas outlined but never filmed explains
that Palpatine's Master taught him how
to manipulate midichlorians to create
life in an attempt to create the perfect
pupil Palpatine created Anakin saying
that from a certain point of view he was
Anakin's father the scene was in script
phase when Lucas cut it but it adds
extra weight to Return of the Jedi
Anakin as Darth Vader tries to draw his
son to the dark side just like his own
father did it's a cool backstory but it
still wouldn't have made Revenge of the
Sith suck any less
Independence Day
remember Independence Day of course you
do it's a great silly movie about
Humanity fighting against aliens and
defeating them with the combined powers
of inspirational public speaking and
also hacking hold up how exactly did
Jeff Goldblum get a computer virus onto
the alien ship it's hard enough getting
a PC to play nice with a Mac well you
guessed it a deleted scene has the
answer remember how Goldblum found out
when the aliens were going to attack by
decoding messages they were sending
through Earth's satellites he used that
information like a Rosetta Stone to
figure out the computers on the crashed
alien ship at Roswell see these patterns
to the repeating sequentially just like
their countdown signal they're using
that frequency for computer
Communications huh
another coordinating their ships from
there he figured out how to ride a virus
specifically for the aliens computers
which still doesn't make a bunch of
sense but it's a step up from magical
hacking so uh take that aliens Welcome
To Earth
The Goonies
remember at the end of The Goonies when
the kids are screaming at their parents
about all their Adventures out of the
blue data starts talking about an
octopus what happened out there
no you didn't forget about the Epic
scene where The Goonies fight an octopus
because it was taken out of the Final
Cut but the scene did survive when The
Goonies are swimming through the lake to
the pirate ship they run into a giant
octopus that tries to eat them all
because what's more piratey than an
octopus-infested Lake nothing that's
what so get your Truffle Shuffle on
because this mystery is solved
the Star Wars universe is a rich tap
estry but there are
irritated subplots to abandoned action
sequences these are the Star Wars
deleted scenes that could have had a big
impact on the franchise
in A New Hope We Meet Luke Skywalker
when he and his uncle Owen purchase
C-3PO and R2D2 from a group of Jawas
it's a fine introduction and it allows
the narrative spine of the film to carry
through the two droids however deleted
scenes from the film revealed that we
were originally going to get to know
Luke in a different way George Lucas
shot several minutes of scenes on
Tatooine that were later cut from the
film which would have shown Luke doing
much more than farming in the scene Luke
sees the space battle that opens the
film through binoculars and goes to show
his friends what he'd seen these scenes
also introduced Luke's friend big Stark
lighter oh big this ride I'm never gonna
get out of here
during their brief interaction Bix
explains his plans to sneak away and
join the Rebel Alliance while the scenes
would have slowed down the film a little
if they'd stayed in they would have also
added a large amount of World building
and helped explain some of Luke's
whinier Tendencies The Empire Strikes
Back features a famous moment in which
Leia plants a big kiss on Luke Skywalker
to make Han Solo jealous
but the moment is later undercut by the
Revelation that Luke and Leia are
brother and sister as it turns out
things could have been much more Awkward
a deleted portion of the kissing scene
takes place before Han enters the room
as Luke and Leia talk alone about his
recovery with his near-death experience
on his mind Luke begins to tell Leia how
he feels about her they almost share a
more intimate kiss but they're
interrupted by C-3PO because that's just
what 3PO was born to do the sequence
would have also featured Luke revealing
his plan to go to Dagobah to Leia adding
even more color to his inner life
Greta was first introduced in what has
become one of the most infamous scenes
in Star Wars history as a bounty hunter
confronting Han Solo but Greedo has a
history in The Phantom Menace one of
Anakin Skywalker's friends turns out to
be a younger version of Greedo in a
deleted scene we see that the kid was
nasty from the start George Lucas shot a
lot of additional footage for Phantom
menace's pod race sequence including
more of the race itself and another
scene set right after the race the
deleted scene shows Anakin and Greedo
getting into a fight because Greedo
accused Anakin of cheating their fight
is broken up by Qui-Gon who tries to
explain to Anakin that he doesn't need
to argue if he knows the truth himself
the scene underlines the anger within
Anakin and also lets us know that Greedo
has always been a jerk for much of
attack of the Clones Anakin Skywalker
and Padme Amidala are on her home planet
of Naboo they're supposed to be there
for security reasons but all that time
alone together creates a romance deleted
scenes from the film revealed that the
Naboo trip included an extended sequence
in which Padme us as her political
career there's also an even longer scene
in which Anakin meets padme's parents
the sequence may have slowed the final
film down a bit but it adds a lot of
depth to Padme we learned that she
wasn't raised as royalty she loves quiet
family life and she's passionate about
helping around the Galaxy we also see
Anakin get grumpy when she tells her
parents that he's not her boyfriend one
of the best things about the prequels is
seeing the Jedi Order during their
greatest days that meant we got to see
lots of Jedi beyond the few we'd met
already sadly the films have to cover so
much ground that we don't get a chance
to get to know most of these other Jedi
they're mostly supporting characters who
barely get a word in a deleted scene
from the final battle and attack of the
Clones gave some of those supporting
Jedi more to do the missing scene is an
action sequence in which Jedi Masters
kiondi Mundi and Plo Koon stage a raid
on a droid control ship the scene was
never finished but at least we got the
Clone Wars
there's a lot going on in Revenge of the
Sith that means several deleted scenes
fell by the wayside and some of them
follow the rise of what would become the
Rebel Alliance these deleted scenes
paint a clear picture of a small group
of worried Senators discussing how to
make a move against Palpatine the
stronger Palpatine gets the closer they
get to Rebellion it's an intriguing
subplot and would have added quite a bit
more context for the future of the
Rebellion if it stayed in the final film
The Force awakens has to carry on a
story that ended on the big screen more
than 30 years earlier and set up a new
story with a new cast of characters
that's a lot of ground to cover and that
means some aspects of the World building
are left to the imagination one of these
has to do with the resistance the
Republic and how General Leia Organa
factors into both Leia played a key role
in the formation of the new Republic but
when the first order Rose many people in
the Republic leadership wouldn't believe
her when she said it was a major threat
to their future so Leia founded the
resistance determined to stop the first
order before they destroyed the Republic
in a weighted scene from The Force
awakens this is given a touch more
detail as Leia sends resistance member
corcella to ask the Republic for help
sadly the scene was cut and we only see
corcella in one shot just before her
death as the first order destroys the
Republic The Last Jedi is the second
film in the sequel trilogy but the first
in that trilogy to really deal with Luke
Skywalker in a major way director Ryan
Johnson had to not just introduce this
new version of Luke but also explain the
complex emotions that led him to abandon
his friends and the force it's one of
the most important parts of the movie
but some things still had to be cut one
of the most powerful Last Jedi deleted
scenes come shortly after Luke figures
out Han is dead we don't get to see Rey
and Chewie tell him that his
brother-in-law and friend is dead but
one deleted scene shows us the aftermath
silent and shaken Luke sits down in his
Hut and tries to deal with the loss of
Han you can see the despair on his face
along with the guilt as he wonders of
things might have been different if he'd
stayed It's a Wonderful performance for
Mark Hamill but it wound up on The
Cutting Room floor while it's really
easy to be upset when directors chop
cool sounding scenes out of our favorite
movies the reality is that deleted
scenes are a necessity but every once in
a while a deleted scene is uncovered
that completely Alters our perception of
a film in fact it could be argued that
some of the most legendary scenes to
ever hit The Cutting Room floor would
have actually improved the films they
were removed from join us as we uncover
the very best deleted scenes that
deserve to be pulled out of the trash
and given their own time to shine in the
spotlight
aliens
after surviving the events of alien
Ellen Ripley wakes up in the sequel to
discover that she spent 57 years
traveling in hypersleep audiences who
saw the original theatrical cut of
aliens assume that Ripley shrugs this
ordeal off for the most part but a
deleted scene that ended up in the 1992
special edition reveals how the
psychological impact of this experience
hurt our heroine far more than anyone
ever realized following her Awakening
Ripley meets company rep Carter Burke
and asks about her daughter insisting on
answers after some hesitation Burke
reluctantly reveals that her daughter
died two years earlier at the age of 66
upon seeing a photograph of Amanda
Ripley aged beyond recognition Sigourney
Weaver's heroine is overcome with shock
and grief promised her that I'd be home
for her birthday
her 11th birthday in hindsight it's hard
to understand why director James Cameron
chose to remove this scene in the first
place not only does the loss of Ripley's
daughter help contextualize the
subsequent bond that she forms with Newt
but it also serves as a stunning
Showcase of Weaver's acting ability
X-Men first Class in 2011 X-Men first
Class rebooted the mutant franchise in
the process revealing how the central
relationship between Charles Xavier and
Eric lyncher came to be with that in
mind it made perfect sense to see these
two bitter Rivals initially become
friends however we didn't expect to see
Xavier telepathically alter the
perceptions of a potential new student
to convince her that Magneto is dressed
in women's clothing
yeah
it's good isn't it
what how did you do that that's right
the Blu-ray edition of first class
revealed a deleted scene in which
Michael Fassbender actually wore a wig
and dressed in drag while recruiting new
students unfortunately this hilarious
moment never made it to Cinemas but now
that it's come to light it's easy to see
why Magneto eventually turned against
his old friend
Terminator 2 Judgment Day here's another
example of James Cameron dropping the
ball on one of his most popular movies
in Terminator 2 Judgment Day John Connor
asks the Terminator about his Mechanical
Mind and discovers that his Newfound
protector can learn human behavior after
being exposed to it for prolonged
periods of time however a deleted scene
found on the special edition of T2
reveals that Skynet limited the
terminator's processors to a read-only
function by default preventing it from
actually understanding human behavior on
a personal level cue a visually stunning
scene during which John and his mother
open up the Terminator skull to manually
alter his CPU was there a problem
no problem
whatsoever
the deleted scene serves as yet another
reminder of how groundbreaking the
visual effects were in T2 but more
importantly the ramifications of what
happened here pay off later in the movie
as the Terminator displays empathy in
the final scene
Mean Girls
one of the defining moments of the
Classic 2014 comedy Mean Girls is when
Katie breaks her crown at the end and
throws out the pieces to the other girls
who deserve the title of Spring Fling
Queen including Frenemy Regina George at
the time audiences assumed Katie and
Regina hadn't yet made up following the
fight that culminated in that brutal bus
ordeal but a deleted scene reveals that
the pair did actually speak before the
prom stop trying to make this about you
I'm the one that got hit by the bus I'm
sorry about all the other stuff too
okay I'm going to forgive you sure
Regina is on pain medication in this
moment but it actually goes a long way
to help humanize her and also further
explains Katie's subsequent act of
kindness It's a shame that audiences
didn't see this conversation play out in
theaters but Mean Girls remains totally
fetched nonetheless stop trying to make
fetch happen it's not going to happen
Blade Runner
the question of whether Rick Deckard is
a replicant has plagued film lovers for
decades however Blade Runner director
Ridley Scott insists the Deckard is an
artificial beam and he included a scene
that arguably proves this in his
official director's cut in typical
puzzling fashion the original cut of
Blade Runner includes a scene in which
Deckard finds an origami unicorn during
his escape with Rachel all audiences
know at this stage is that a fellow
Blade Runner named Gaff left this behind
for Deckard but the reason why is
unclear however in a deleted scene that
Scott included in later versions Deckard
dreams of a unicorn
the suggestion here is that Gaff left
this origami for him because he knows
deckard's memories and innermost
thoughts how would he know this because
Deckard is a replicant in these memories
were implants
the thing
John Carpenter's sci-fi horror classic
the thing has inspired debates
surrounding its protagonist and whether
he can be trusted by the films in the
Antarctic base where Pilot R.J McCready
has been sent as occupied by a
shape-shifting alien that impersonates
the people it kills in the final scene
McCready and fellow Survivor Childs are
the only two Who Remain leaving
audiences to guess whether one of them
is secretly the monster in Disguise why
don't we just
wait here for a little while
see what happens in an alternate ending
it's revealed that the alien does in
fact survive escaping the Antarctic base
in the form of a Husky this deleted
scene strongly suggests that McCready
definitely did die no matter who the
monster was impersonating however this
still doesn't explain which survivor
held A Deadly Secret at the end of the
original theatrical cut but some
eagle-eyed fans noticed that child's
doesn't appear to be breathing in that
last scene whereas mccready's icy breath
can be seen in the air suggesting that
child's isn't really Human After All
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice with
director Zack Snyder trying to turn the
DC EU into a viable Cinematic Universe a
lot of Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice felt rushed at times characters
even seem to possess knowledge that
should have been out of their reach the
most obvious example occurs toward the
end when an imprisoned Lex Luthor
alludes to an evil force that threatens
to destroy the Earth the Bells already
been
and they've heard it
comic book fans assumed that this
ominous warning was linked to Darkseid
in some way and they were right as his
nephew Steppenwolf arrived soon after to
cause Havoc for Heroes in Justice League
but how did Superman's arch nemesis know
Steppenwolf would travel to earth in the
first place in the ultimate edition of
dawn of Justice a deleted scene set on
the Kryptonian ship Luther captured
reveals that the megalomaniac
experienced direct contact with
Steppenwolf
sure the character design changed
dramatically between films but at least
we finally know the truth about what
Luther was talking about while trapped
in his cell I believe in truth
but I'm also a big fan of Justice
Star Wars Episode 6 Return of the Jedi
for decades audiences have argued over
the existence of numerous plot holes in
the Star Wars franchise the one that
arguably sticks out the most is why Luke
Skywalker was never told the true
identity of his father sure this
Omission built impressive amounts of
tension between Skywalker and Darth
Vader but one has to question why
Obi-Wan Kenobi didn't tell him long
before the pair finally clashed in
battle well it turns out that Return of
the Jedi originally included another
line that explains exactly why Kenobi
originally withheld this Vital
Information and it's all because of Yoda
when Luke returns to Yoda's bedside one
last time the fuzzy green Jedi reveals
that he forbade Kenobi from telling him
the truth about Vader
[Music]
Obi-Wan would have told you long ago
not only does this deleted scene solve
one of the most troubling plot holes in
the franchise it also sheds new light on
Kenobi's relationship with Yoda and
their power dynamic Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows part one long before
Voldemort reemerged to cause havoc in
Harry Potter's life the young wizard had
to deal with an evil far closer to home
his abusive Aunt Uncle and Cousin who
adopted him following his parents deaths
it's easy to picture these characters
purely in terms of light and darkness
but a deleted scene removed from Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows part 1
reminds us that everyone contains
elements of both including Harry's rude
cousin Dudley dursley
I don't think you're a waste of space
thanks
well it's unfortunate that this parting
was cut it's still heartening that fans
eventually got to see this important
moment play out in Live Action Game of
Thrones has always been a pretty
sprawling TV show and plenty of material
has ended up on The Cutting Room floor
but though these scenes were deleted
they're still fascinating to explore
especially since these moments could
have subtly changed the course of the
story or at least our perception of
events let's explore some of the more
substantial moments I'd never made at
the final cut the execution of
Littlefinger was one of the most
shocking moments in the season 7 finale
but how did Sansa and Arya Stark come to
learn about his whole lifetime of crimes
in an interview with variety actor Isaac
Hempstead Rai who portrays Bran Stark
revealed that he shot a deleted sequence
of Sophie Turner who portrays Sansa in
the scene Sansa reportedly consulted
with bran just ahead of littlefinger's
trial as you may recall Santa was
convinced her sister Arya was out to
assassinate her in order to become the
lady of Winterfell Arya suspected the
same of Sansa and it was all thanks to
that master manipulator Littlefinger
viewers were sweating buckets watch in
the season 7 finale since it looks like
one of the Stark's sisters might kill
the other but then sansarinaria flipped
the script sentencing Littlefinger to
death revealing their Feud to be an
elaborate ruse thank you for all your
many lessons Lord Baelish
I will never forget them it was a big
twist but it seemed to leave a bit of a
plot hole behind too how will the star
children suddenly so certain of
littlefinger's history of manipulation
and betrayal according to Hempstead
Wright a deleted scene from the episode
would have cleared up any ambiguity it
revealed exactly how the Stark sisters
learned of Littlefinger schemes and it
would have let audiences see how Sansa
and Arya arrived at the decision to
execute him in the deleted scene bran
uses his Newfound abilities as a
three-eyed Raven to peer into
littlefingers past another thing every
underhanded thing had ever done in his
quest for power Hamstead Wright told
variety the story was that it suddenly
occurred to Sansa that she had a huge
CCTV department at a discretion and it
might be a good idea to check with bran
first before she gets her own sister
though audience says can kind of still
fill in the blanks without the scene its
inclusion would have threaded the plot
together with a little more clarity it
also would have shed more light on
Bran's immense Powers giving us a much
stronger impression of how extraordinary
his gifts really are Bran's ability to
access the history of man and the
secrets of Westeros as an astonishing
skill and the potentially powerful
weapon as was made clear in season 8
Bran's knowledge that John is a rightful
heir to the Seven Kingdoms has Spartan
and fortunate chain of events one that's
played an important part in Daenerys
targaryens descend into madness Sansa is
undergone a remarkable transformation
since we first met a dreamy young girl
looking forward to marriage and one
person who's had a major hand in her
development is sandor Clegane otherwise
known as the Hound throughout much of
Game of Thrones he seemed ultimately
drawn to and repulsed by sansa's
innocence frequently calling her little
bird with a mixture of sweetness and
condescension
a little bit
a little bit of course the Hound uses
that nickname again in the fourth
episode of Season 8 when the Dynamics
between the two are remarkably different
it's a scene that highlights just how
much Sansa has grown throughout the
course of Game of Thrones
you've changed little bird
yeah one deleted scene all the way back
in season two depicts a Sansa who's
already prepared to stand up to the
Hound
saying I don't know any songs
not anymore instead of a quivering wave
we see a young woman who's perfectly
willing to stand her ground and perhaps
that was a problem the scene of her
standing up for herself even a little
bit could have been seen as too much too
soon as far as sansa's development is
concerned Sansa and the hounds season 8
reunion certainly wouldn't have been
half as Bittersweet if she'd already
demonstrated the potential for such
strength way back in season 2. tormund
has always been right at the center of
the tension between the Night's Watch
and the wildlings he's helpful to the
Night's Watch but he's not sentimental
about their history he's committed to
being part of the free folk but he's
also Jon Snow's friend when John was the
commander of the Night's Watch he
welcomed tormund and other wildlings
across the wall that brought attention
to its boiling point resulting in the
slaying of Jon Snow in a deleted scene
from season 5 that would have taken
place before Jon's death and
Resurrection so Alice a Thorne one of
Snow's eventual Killers verbally spars
with tormund he lets tormund know just
how much he distrusts him and how
literally likes housing him tormund
croughly replies he must no longer be in
charge then it's a moment of intense
foreshadowing but had the scene been
included in the show it might have made
tormund seem partially responsible for
Jon Snow's murder however involuntarily
though he didn't wield a dagger his
aggressive needling of Alisa might have
been perceived as a straw that broke the
camel's back audiences might have blamed
tormund for sir Alice's subsequent
actions though the scene is appropriate
for that era of the show it may well of
Caster Paul over an alliance that has
since helped shape the future of
Westeros Game of Thrones Minds conflict
from absolutely every angle life against
death woman against man religion against
cynicism another major Clash the ongoing
animosity between the nobility and
common folk of Westeros The Prostitute
Shea had a pretty long run on Game of
Thrones but her luck eventually run out
first there was her damaging testimony
against Tyrion Lannister who then
tragically killed her when he
encountered her in his father's bed it
was tragic and it was extreme Bertha
deleted scene between Shay and Braun
reveals a far more tender side to the
conflict and it might change how you
view Shay's actions in the scene bran
commiserates with shea as a fellow
commoner these people even the good ones
I use this as a police
and when we're no longer in use the spit
us out it's the kindest we've ever seen
bran and the moment emphasizes the
difficult position that Shay was in we
have to adapt to circumstances is what
I'm saying learn some new tricks with
this seen in mind what happens between
Shea and Tyrion becomes even more
complicated yes she does something awful
but this scene dares to ask what choice
did she have
Grand maester Pi cell was always a
conniving man even when acting like a
daughtering old fool he delighted in
playing passive aggressive games and he
never missed an opportunity to dismiss
and disrespect Tyrion but his detestable
nature often went completely unnoticed
by other characters on Game of Thrones
it even went unnoticed by many people
watching the show Bertha deleted scene
between pie cell and Tywin Lannister
would have changed that Dynamic
enormously pycel interrupts Tywin while
he's fishing and as usual he's playing
the fall in order to seem
non-threatening and inept unimpressed by
the charade Tywin cuts off by cells
babbling
am I the only one to see through this
performance this certainly changes a
dynamic between paisal and Tywin it also
suggests that most of the other people
in King's Landing are comparably Daft
the scene doesn't just make Tywin seem
more formidable it also changes how we
see pycel now he seems like a dangerous
and devious man instead of a mild
annoyance
in the second season of Game of Thrones
Daenerys learns an important lesson in
trust after she's ferociously betrayed
by a handmaiden Daria please he said
you'd never leave carf alive at Carmen
Daria meets a holy and fortunate end
with Daenerys sealing her inside a vault
to die which is an arguably kind of a
harsh way to take somebody out as it
turns out we didn't even see the worst
of doria's actions in a deleted scene
from season 2 she gleefully strangles
daenerys's handmaiden Eerie to death of
course that scene effectively turns
Doria into a far more Insidious
character and it makes her betrayal seem
so much worse than what we ever saw on
screen the white walkers were always a
major threat in Game of Thrones but it
was also a major challenge to get the
people of Westeros to believe the threat
was real Jon Snow spent an enormous
chunk of screen time arguing about the
Walkers though few people were ever
willing to take his warnings or Brand's
Visions to Heart boy claims to have seen
dead men on the March Beyond the Wall
thanks to the magical help of a raven
with three eyes as it is a bit much but
in a deleted season 2 scene that we
never got to see it's revealed that
Tywin Lannister took the white walkers
quite seriously from early on after
hearing stories of corpses with blue
eyes on their bone white Masters Tywin
discusses sending an Envoy to Mance
Raider and then the king Beyond the Wall
this plot development would have
seriously changed their perception of
Tywin and it would have considerably
raised the stakes for the Lannisters as
a whole had the scene aired we would
have seen the first major house star
preparing for battle with the white
walkers far ahead of time while pretty
much everyone else was too busy being
skeptical renley's death was a linchpin
of several plot threads melisandre's
dark and complex magic the tyrell's
insatiable thirst for power and the war
of the five Kings Renly had the charm
and Charisma that Stannis lacked he had
the backing of a large and fruitful
house and Brilliant women like Marjorie
at his side at this point it's all too
easy to forget what a genuine threat he
was but above and beyond that Randy was
loris's lover and the deleted scene from
season 2 illustrates their love with the
tenderness that's rather unusual for the
world of Game of Thrones in the scene
Loris laments is an ability to stop
renley's murder confiding in his sister
Marjorie that he feels somewhat
responsible for his Lover's death
Marjorie urges llores to turn his
attention to the family
she's at War this scene makes her
tyrell's emotional Stakes all the more
clear it's easy to see Marjorie as
conniving above all else but this
unusually touching moment illustrates
that she still very much loves her
brother
olena Tyrell was one of the most
fearsome characters in Game of Thrones a
brilliant strategist a cynical plutter
and a devoted grandmother she was a
woman who do anything to protect her
family and their interests case in point
her murder of Joffrey Baratheon at his
wedding in a deleted scene from season
six she discusses the Lannisters with
her son mate Tyrell after mace has made
cersei's master of coin he's evidently
unable to see how it's being manipulated
but Elena sees exactly what's going on
and she's determined to keep Loris and
Marjorie as safe as possible Cersei
Lannister sent you to Bravos to get you
out of her way and she sent the bloody
King's Guard to make certain you stayed
there the scene brings to light exactly
how close his plan came to ending in
failure and how enormously the tyrells
would go on to lose in season seven and
thus how powerful Cersei truly is but
the last season of the series though
forces were arrayed on both the Tyrell
and Lannister sides it all came down to
a game of wits between the queen of
Westeros and the queen of thorns the
dire wolves have always been more than
pets their Fates are foreshadow and
influenced the face of the Stark
children from the very beginning from
ladies death and sansa's subsequent
suffering the gray wind's mutilation and
Rob's murder at the Red Wedding in a
deleted scene from season 7 John gives
ghosts an important task before he sets
off to meet Daenerys keeps Sansa safe
ghost is essentially the only Stark of
direwolf left yes there's still nymeria
but that's the story for another day the
fact that Jon entrusted this job to
ghost as a sign of just How Deeply he
cares for Sansa it also emphasizes how
important Sansa Arya John and bran are
to each other their strong Alliance has
survived that of the Lannisters the
tyrells and the targaryens ghosts is a
part of John or at least he used to be
before the king in the north up and
ditched him in season eight you really
do Know Nothing Jon Snow
movies for any number of reasons
sometimes they grind the plot to a halt
while other times they clash with the
tone of the rest of the movie often
they're just totally unnecessary these
deleted scenes however are some of the
greatest ever filmed which makes it even
more of a shame that they ended up on
The Cutting Room floor
arguably the most important and
horrifying scene in Andy muschetti's
adaptation of it is the debut of
Pennywise Stephen King's Unforgettable
Eater of Worlds
spawning a thousand memes and a thousand
more nightmares the moment when
Pennywise lures Georgie denbro into the
sewers below Dairy is as terrifying as
it is instantly memorable and it's hard
to imagine the situation could have
played out differently but it turns out
that musketti actually directed a
surprise alternate opening for it which
ends in a very different way
[Music]
see you later
while this was obviously filmed as a gag
muskete's alternate opening does provoke
some interesting thoughts about the
story
if Georgie had survived pennywise's
attack it's entirely possible that the
evil demons Reign Over the town of Derry
would have continued unchallenged after
all the murder of Georgie was the
beginning of the end of his demise even
if he didn't know it at the time when we
first meet Steve Rogers in The Avengers
he's taken out his frustration and
despair on a punching bag as memories of
his life during World War II flashed
through his mind but there's also an
entire deleted sequence which
demonstrates just how depressed cap has
really become the scene opens with Steve
alone in his apartment watching World
War II propaganda films after pouring
through the government files of his long
gone friends he briefly considers
calling his old flame Peggy Carter but
never picks up the phone Steve then
wanders through a city filled with cell
phones and fancy cars completely lost in
the 21st century before winding up at a
cafe
is for her number you he then
takes a lonely subway ride to the boxing
gym where we meet him in the actual film
it's a shame the sequence was cut from
the movie since it shows the full extent
of Steve's isolation and makes it a more
satisfying Victory when he finally finds
his place in the world
Marvel movie dads are often rotten and
Thanos has got to be the worst of the
bunch even his favorite daughter Gamora
has suffered a fair bit of abuse in his
hands but while the relationship is
incredibly Twisted the two still feel
some affection for each other an
Infinity war did a good job of exploring
their complex dynamic in a short amount
of time how however there's one deleted
scene that digs even deeper into the
relationship it opens in thanos's throne
room with the Mad Titan showing his
imprisoned daughter a scene from their
past back when she was his most trusted
Assassin by the look of it
you seem content enough at the time
but Gamora explains that her
self-loathing only started to disappear
when she joined up with the Guardians of
the Galaxy even a guilt trip from Thanos
isn't enough to get her back on side you
had a family here little one he just
didn't care what happened to her while
the scene isn't exactly necessary to the
story it does give some color to one of
the movie's Most Fascinating
relationships
a deleted scene doesn't need to be long
to be great take this moment from
Spider-Man 2 for example the scene comes
after Peter Parker has given up on his
crime fighting career and is ready to
finally live a normal life having thrown
his suit into a garbage can eventually
the suit makes its way to J Jonah
Jameson the daily bugles cantankerous
editor is thrilled that Spider-Man is
called it quits but in this deleted
scene we learned that maybe there's a
reason why Jameson dislikes Spidey so
much
oh
even though this scene is incredibly
brief it's a hysterical moment that
suggests Jameson might be a bigger
Spider-Man fan than he cares to admit
the weightlifting sequence is one of the
best moments from M Night shyamalan's
unbreakable how much is it Dad
about 350 pounds it's a triumphant
moment for the self-doubting David but
in one deleted scene he gets an extra
bit of reassurance that he's really
something special after impressing his
kid David Goes to visit the weight room
at the football stadium where he works
and successfully lifts nearly 500 pounds
it's a nice comic sting to close the
scene and although as Shyamalan himself
pointed out it was just a bit redundant
coming straight after the basement
sequence but that doesn't mean it's not
a lot of fun Hannibal Lecter is a stone
cold psychopath he's a genuine monster
who feeds on others both emotionally and
literally but while serial killers
aren't usually big on feelings there's a
deleted scene from The Silence of the
Lambs that shows Hannibal is actually
capable of empathy locked away in his
underworld prison Hannibal launches into
a monologue about the psychology behind
his fellow killer Buffalo Bill
her belly wasn't born a killer Clarice
how now he was made one through years of
systematic abuse tellingly Hannibal
isn't speaking in his usual
condescending tone you can actually hear
the sympathy in his voice
Billy's houses will be very small with
tiny Windows no flowers no pets
no ties no sun he ends his impassioned
speech with a line that is both chilling
and strangely sad how Billy he wants to
be reborn Clarice
and he will be reborn only segments of
Hannibal's speech are heard in the
movie's theatrical cut but had the
original scene remained intact it might
have offered audiences a deeper look
into Bill's Twisted mind and a better
understanding of Hannibal Lecter himself
Captain Quint has got to be one of the
greatest movie characters of all time
played by the inimitable Robert Shaw
Quint is a Salty Sea Dog who loves beer
hates sharks and has fun antagonizing
Wealthy College Boys it soon becomes
clear that there's a lot more going on
beneath quint's strange exterior but
early in the film he's played as a
cackling coot with a bizarre sense of
humor one deleted scene from Jaws
demonstrates just how odd Quint can be
requiring some fishing line that's
strong enough to catch sharks he drops
by the local music store to buy some
piano wire there he finds a young boy
practicing the clarinet and starts to
sing along
[Applause]
granted the scene doesn't really
contribute much to the film and would
have done some damage to the story's
pacing but it's a hilarious performance
from Shaw and a welcome chance to spend
some more time with Quint
one of the defining character traits of
lethal weapon's Martin Riggs is his
unflinching willingness to put himself
In Harm's Way this is a guy who's always
hoping that somebody will end his lonely
life and his desire for death is made
all the clearer in this deleted scene
where Riggs squares off against the
schoolyard sniper Riggs gets a call that
there's a gunman firing at a school and
the SWAT team isn't going to show up
anytime soon naturally he makes his move
[Music]
get out you're in the line of fire get
down
when he finally reaches the sniper he
doesn't hold back
[Music]
yeah it's not entirely necessary to the
plots but don't pretend it's not badass
few deleted scenes have captured the
hearts of movie lovers quite like the
Jitterbug musical number that was cut
from The Wizard of Oz clocking in at six
whole minutes the dance sequence took
five weeks to rehearse and perform
costing MGM a total of eighty thousand
dollars reports suggest that the scene
was ultimately cut to reduce the film's
running time but it's also possible that
the upbeat nature of the song Simply
didn't fit with the story's darker
elements written by composer Harold
Arlen and Lyricist e.y harburg the scene
was based around a pink and blue insect
that caused its victims to dance
uncontrollably Once Bitten although
their Jitterbug wasn't included in the
movie's theatrical cut hints towards its
existence still remain
it just goes to show some things can't
be disposed of so easily a deleted scene
from the Elvis biopic features none
other than one of country's biggest
movie stars well sort of here's how an
early cut of the film nearly paired the
kick with one of country's most lasting
talents a critically acclaimed biopic
Elvis provides an intimate glimpse into
the legendary performer's life its
Dynamic approach to Presley is supported
by Austin Butler's striking portrayal of
the performer which helped him win a
Golden Globe for best performance by an
actor in a motion picture drama the
Project's bold visuals and the Lively
soundtrack give it a rhythmic quality
worthy of Presley's Legacy credit for
this vibrant blend goes to Elvis
director baz luhrmann his previous work
has a style all its own bringing
together inspired choices from the
Realms of art film pop culture
literature and music for Elvis the
director once again came up with a
soundtrack that utilizes top talents
from today and the performers signature
songs new contributions from dojicat and
Eminem alongside Presley's most famous
songs it also remixes some of the
singer's catalog for dramatic effect
lerman's use of music to amplify a
moment or emotion is on Full display
throughout the movie still the director
regrets losing out on one song the
track's placement in a crucial scene
along with the meaning behind it tips
its hat to a beloved musical icon one of
the final scenes of Elvis is a
heartbreaking look at the artist's then
harrowing life sitting alone with
ex-wife Priscilla Presley Elvis worries
that people will forget him
and nobody's gonna remember me it's a
portrait of a singer facing an uncertain
future as the world he knew collapses
for the filmmaker this moment shows how
Elvis and his first wife remained on
good terms after their split but it also
amounts to a death scene Lerman told
variety I always wanted another moment
where Priscilla came back into his life
and that they were friends in a way when
he walks on that plane and it takes off
we don't need to see him die he's dead
the interview also gave Lerman a chance
to speak on Elvis saying I will always
love you to Priscilla before he boards
the plane the backstory relates to a
missed opportunity between music royalty
namely Presley and Dolly Parton in the
film Elvis was set to sing the famous
song to Priscilla in those Quiet Moments
in the car Lerman made the decision to
do away with the brief moment but not
before acknowledging why the scene
didn't make the cut the director
explained to variety we just didn't know
how we would fit it into the schedule
you can't drive the car because of
gasoline so it's my guy Fletch pulling
the car with a piece of rope there's no
plane and no no tarmac just a wind
machine and the actors in real life
Elvis Presley planned to perform Dolly
Parton's legendary song I will always
love you but it seems once again that
his longtime manager Colonel Tom Parker
had the final say the problem was a
disturbing one for songwriter Parton who
was allegedly asked to give up half her
publishing rights by Parker pardon told
W in a 2021 interview I wanted to hear
Elvis sing it and it broke my heart I
cried all night but I had to keep that
copyright in my pocket you have to take
care of your business Parton went on to
explain that Elvis did actually sing I
Will Always Love You to Priscilla when
the two of them divorced a gesture which
she says touched her and while she had
to wait until 1992 before the song
became a huge hit on the billboard pop
charts courtesy of the late Whitney
Houston she remains proud of its lasting
Legacy pardon told W they also played
the song at Whitney Houston's funeral
after that I thought I bet they'll play
the same song when I go
when it comes to genres horror is one of
the hardest to get right the smallest
detail can break the spell filmmakers
rely on to suck viewers in and get them
invested in the scenes that'll fuel
nightmares later it's all about timing
and balance so it's no surprise a lot of
otherwise good scenes can get the ax
sometimes those lost scenes are awesome
whether they give new insight into a
character or hint at a sequel they're
worth revisiting let's do exactly that
starting with
a killer confrontation the saw series
started out pretty basic two guys leg
chains hacksaws you know the drill
things would eventually get more
complicated but we could usually count
on Amanda staying relatively strong up
to her violent end at least as a victim
turned willing accomplice she needed to
be a little more complicated than most
of the other characters who were of
course usually just tortured meat making
the jump to becoming jigsaw's Pawn is
almost unimaginable and this deleted
scene from Saw 3 is a glimpse into that
struggle
very rock star
sorry you're here it's very rock star
it's too bad we never got to see it
because it's particularly effective in
the series that could have benefited
from some relatable moments like this
it's a flashback to an atom who's
oblivious to what's in store for him and
a chance meeting that's about to go
horribly wrong we all know it even if
they don't
I'll see you there
Henry's bad day it was one of the most
terrifying movies of 2017. Pennywise
gave everyone another reason to fear
clowns but that wasn't all for the
losers Club who also had classroom bully
Henry Bowers to deal with they know
Henry's a little unstable and we know it
too one blink and you'd miss a deleted
scene would have helped make the full
extent of his psychotic break completely
clear Henry sits in a car watching our
favorite group of losers head into the
most terrifying house we've ever seen
yes even including this one he has
company but friends Belch and Victor
aren't feeling too talkative considering
what he's done to them and that just
really brings it home about just what
kind of bully the losers Club has had to
deal with on a daily basis that's the
very definition of horror say what you
will about Pennywise but at least Henry
makes your own school bully look
positively Pleasant evil Dead's extra
dark details the 2013 reboot of Evil
Dead was as ridiculously bloody as you'd
expect and director Fede Alvarez once
told collider I know we ordered a truck
of blood the other day that was 50 000
gallons just for one scene that's a shot
lacking amount of blood even though most
made it on screen for an insanely
blood-soaked finale there were still a
few details left on The Cutting Room
floor in the original ending Mia's
brother Steve Burns down the cabin it's
a sacrificial move as he traps himself
and their possessed friend a deleted
shot shows a little more of what happens
inside the cabin as it's going up in
flames and spoiler alert it's not good
for Steve and in case you've ever
wondered just what happens when the
blood stop flowing and the bodies are
done falling this cut scene shows just
how Mia got back to civilization
thank you
are you okay kiddo
[Music]
neither shot adds anything to the story
but it's possible that last glimpse of
Steve might have been setting up a
sequel we hope
[Music]
[Applause]
groovy a breathless confession 2016's
don't breathe might be one of the most
tense claustrophobic Thrillers ever made
and it starts when three thieves decide
to break into the home of a blind man
it's not long before they realize
they've picked the wrong house and it's
Steven Lang's performance as the
intended victim that's at the heart of
the film since he doesn't have much
dialogue it's extra terrifying when he
does speak like he does in this deleted
scene
my daughter
was
my life
and that might be why this ended up on
The Cutting Room floor it might have
given him just too much to say going
into some pretty explicit and
heartbreaking detail about the accident
that killed his daughter while it might
help us understand more about him the
explanation is ultimately unnecessary
the scene would have thrown a wrench
into the film's pacing but Lang's
reading of it is no less mesmerizing
than the rest of his performance
extra scares most deleted scenes are
short and sweet but 2002's the ring lost
an entire subplot involving an accused
murderer played by Chris Cooper who shot
scenes to bookend the film while these
scenes unfortunately were never made
available to the public a few other
deleted scenes have slipped out one of
the most nerve-wracking is an incredibly
creepy one in which Noah makes a
horrifying Discovery as he heads off to
investigate the classic sort of creepy
cabin unfortunately for him a small boat
floating just offshore in the lake grabs
his attention
[Music]
it's effective but maybe too effective
the ultimately unnecessary scene and
subplot may have had the effect of
lessening similar scares at earlier and
later points in the film and we can all
agree the ring is pretty epic without
the added weight
given a nightmare on Elm Street's
immense popularity and its status in the
modern horror film Canon you would think
there would be very few facts or secrets
about the 1984 horror classic left to
discover but thanks to an obscure
deleted scene you would be oh so wrong a
scrapped scene from the film has
recently resurfaced online and it
completely changes everything we thought
we knew about the burnt up serial killer
Freddy Krueger and his most well-known
would-be victim 15 year old Nancy
Thompson the sequence first included in
the 1996 LaserDisc release of a
Nightmare on Elm Street and only
included sporadically in later home
video releases is an extended version of
the conversation Nancy under mother
Marge have in the original cut of the
film Marge takes Nancy down to their
basement and explains to her that Kruger
was a filthy child murderer who was
freed on a legal technicality Marge says
that she and the other parents of
Springwood Ohio tracked Kruger down and
discovered him hiding in a boiler room
where he used to take his young victims
the parents then Dows the place in
gasoline and lit it up in an attempt to
get rid of Kruger for good a strategy
echoed by Nancy at the end of the film
in the theatrical version of a Nightmare
on Elm Street Nancy's mother assures her
that Kruger can't get to her and that
he's dead because she's killed him Marge
then pulls out one of Kruger's regular
gloves to prove that he's gone and that
Nancy can rest easy but in this
alternate scene there's additional
Exposition between the moment Marge
amidst a burning Kruger alive and when
she unwraps the Killer's famous weapon
Nancy's mother discloses a real
motivation behind murdering Kruger she
and her fellow neighborhood parents
wanted Revenge after Kruger had already
killed some of their own children that's
right Nancy and her friends all had
siblings Kruger had already murdered
you too Nancy
a few sentences from her mom Nancy
realizes that Kruger isn't just some
random deranged man with supernatural
abilities and the desire to kill
children and teenagers he isn't even
just a killer who seeks Vengeance after
getting burned alive all those years ago
no he's a murderer who took away a piece
of Nancy's family who left her parents
bereft and her without a sibling and who
also did the same to her closest friends
and their families
sister once as such this reveals to
alter the entire dynamic between Nancy
and Kruger and instills in the teen a
new reason to go after the monster
though the deleted scene has been
readily available to watch online for
years now there's a chance plenty A
Nightmare on Elm Street fans haven't
seen it yet which is huge considering
how drastically it could change their
thinking of both the original 1984 film
and the film series as a whole if Craven
had kept this version of the
storytelling session in the theatrical
version of a Nightmare on Elm Street it
potentially could have had a domino
effect on the events of every franchise
installment thereafter each new series
entry picks up and expands on what came
before it so if the official nightmare
lore included the fact that Nancy had a
sibling who was killed that could have
been used to explain her re-emergence in
1987's a Nightmare on Elm Street 3 Dream
Warriors it definitely would have
provided her with even more motivation
to put Kruger down in the classic
original nightmare as if slipping a
supernatural phone tongue wasn't enough
there's a layer to the office even the
most die-hard fans may be oblivious to
the many hours of deleted scenes that
never made it to Prime Time some
episodes have so many that they nearly
constitute separate episodes under
themselves and many are just as funny as
the jokes we still quote endlessly it's
hard to forget Michael fresh off his
trip to a Jamaican Resort banging on a
steel drum and serenading his employees
with the news that he's feeling
[Applause]
that's all I know so far but I'm Gonna
Keep practicing it's good
it's good he has no idea that he isn't
introducing his colleagues to Island
living but preventing them from doing
their work and simultaneously no idea
that the sunbathing photo of Jan is
about to blow up his office in this
deleted scene he's almost sweet in his
sincerity Michael sounds ridiculous as
he attempts to remember the lyrics to
Harry Belafonte's Deo and no he's
nowhere near pulling off this Vibe he
describes wanting every day to feel like
he did for him in Jamaica when he woke
with the sunrise ate a mango and looked
forward to hours spent with someone he
loved Michael has no idea how silly he
looks how messy things are about to get
with Jan and his job or how much he's
going to annoy his employees he's just
happy to be enjoying his Newfound sense
of vacation identity
Ryan's descent from good-natured temp to
sleazy pretentious grifter was one of
the office's most satisfying character
arcs it's not that he was ever
diabolical just deeply and unrelentingly
smug even at the depths of his low
points from sporting bleached hair in a
bowling alley to being driven to work by
his mom he never lost his grip on his
own unearned sense of superiority
audiences love to hate Ryan because the
world is so full of Ryan's he tried on
being a hipster photographer the world's
laziest startup Mastermind and even the
dad dumping his baby on a stranger to
follow an unendingly codependent
relationship this deleted scene gives
the viewer a bit of insight into how
Ryan rationalizes being Ryan as he
explains to Kevin someone else does
everything bad he's ever perpetrated and
that guy is always in Forever the old
Ryan he's Ryan 2.0 now and now still has
to Bear the weight of another man's
misdeeds why should he be punished when
the sins of this other man already
pressed down upon him each day it's
utterly obnoxious and makes total sense
plus it makes the moment when Kevin
pulls the same trick on him all the more
sweet
Jim and Michael's relationship took many
forms like when Jim confided in his
bumbling boss about his feelings for Pam
it was a genuine friendship other times
it became a game of Jim seeing just how
much he could get away with under the
nose of his boss once in a while it grew
openly adversarial but it never stopped
mattering from the moment they were
introduced to the day Michael left for
Colorado this deleted scene from local
ad is an example of the kindness that
was always the foundation of Jim and
Michael's camaraderie yes Jim is pulling
a fast one on Michael culminating in
Michael's surrender of his own office
Michael is made to look silly in
contrast to Jim's knowing prankster
charm but Jim is genuinely helping his
friend get into the right headspace and
by the end of the episode he arranges a
special screening of the Michael Scott
director's cut at Poor Richard's Pub
when Michael needs a suit to play off
Jim steps in to provide Michael
meanwhile gives him a creative Outlet in
his work day
perhaps the office's greatest trick was
its casting of real-life rock star Creed
Bratton as a fictionalized version of
himself bratton's performance never
entirely strayed from the truth of his
Origins the former musician was in the
1960s band The Grassroots and ended up
playing a bizarre alternate universe
interpretation of himself in the office
the character was a flower child through
and through from the mung beans he
sprouted on a damp paper towel in his
desk drawer to his fake ID machine he
sometimes forgot to do his job but he'd
find a way to cover in this deleted
scene Creed behaved as he never had
before
competently we get to watch the man who
once toured with the likes of Janice
Joplin and the doors rock out on a
Pennsylvania party boat playing the
electric guitar like he was born to it
and now I do quality assurance for a
paper company
as you can imagine uh drugs played a
part have this been included it would
have been the only acknowledgment of the
history of the actor character prior to
the finale in which he finally plays an
acoustic song the lateness of that
reveal is a lot of fun to watch but the
deleted scene shows the Dunder Mifflin
crew completely baffled at their
colleague's skill he might not be able
to last more than 90 seconds on a phone
call but he can play like he never left
Woodstock
the fake fire that led to Stanley's
heart attack has become legendary on the
office it was a great opening scene from
the escalation of Dwight's cigarette in
a trash can to the moment Angela's cat
falls out of the ceiling but social
media has given the clip New Life
circulating everywhere from Tumblr to
Twitter Stanley collapsing is just the
cherry on top of a strange comedy Sunday
I'm going to give
it don't give a mouth to mouth for this
one don't follow it
in the deleted scene Michael buys a
portable defibrillator and you're fairly
certain he won't actually electrocute
someone but the office has never been a
show afraid to hurt its characters after
all someone already had a heart attack
and there was that episode all about
Michael hitting Meredith with his car
but the funny comes from Michael getting
into it with his arch nemesis in the
office Toby by the Time Michael makes
his way to the annex and asks for a
handshake from his greatest enemy you're
nearly convinced that Michael might just
send a second employee to the hospital
lucky for Toby the prank is obvious and
Michael doesn't succeed but for a moment
the audience is perfectly suspended
between horror and hilarity
who could have imagined that Phyllis
with her love of gaudy makeovers
charming handicrafts and overwhelming
perfume would have ended up so truly
bizarre her marriage went from being a
lovely facet of the office part to the
most sexual relationship on the show she
took revenge on Angela for crimes
committed in the name of party planning
and hey remember that time she revealed
that she gave up a child for adoption
and wondered if Aaron might be that very
baby phyllis's deaths were strange funny
and often pretty endearing but in one
deleted scene things take a turn for the
wildly morbid Phyllis straight up
confesses to manslaughter that she and
Bob only narrowly got away with a crime
she isn't even able to convince herself
into dismissing it's humor so dark that
it makes sense that it was cut but as a
deleted scene cast into the quasi-canon
of the show it's truly horrifically
hilarious
before Andy was in and out of love with
Aaron before he was the boss he was a
fumbling salesman with nothing but a
Cornell degree to his name among the
earliest hits he would take was the
moment he realized the young woman he'd
been seeing was in fact an underage high
schooler the office pulled a bit more
comedy from the otherwise criminal
situation in this deleted scene Andy
cartoonishly confronts his girlfriend
Jim attempts to keep Andy from
incriminating himself and it becomes
more and more clear just how thoroughly
she and her friends were using him for
access to the adult World cutting this
scene made the plotline more focused on
Andy's failure to establish himself in
Scranton and made it less cringe-worthy
sometimes comedy comes from the stuff
you don't see it makes sense that we
don't get to see much of Michael
splashing around in the titular Koi pond
of this sixth season episode especially
when much of the story hinges on exactly
how he fell in but a deleted scene which
shows the security camera footage of the
fall and its aftermath reveals the whole
Affair as a Showcase of Comedy greatness
Corel shows off his slapstick chops to
an extent rarely seen in the show
somehow managing to drag the event into
an operatic Odyssey he repeatedly
underestimates how far the edge of the
pond is as he slips and stumbles the
fish are bewildered and as we learn
later in the episode endangered by
Michael's pratfalls Michael the
custodian called again apparently akoy
has died
it's a fish and through it all the
security camera sweeps calmly back and
forth there's just something perfectly
absurd about it and reminds us of just
how good physical comedy can be
Jim and Dwight's rivalry was a pillar of
the office from beginning to end what
made their tension so special was the
fact that Dwight never stopped believing
himself to be the superior man despite
the many many times Jim took him down a
peg Dwight is according to himself the
true Authority in the office in alpha
male a genius and so entirely perfect at
being himself that his second life
virtual Persona just happened to also be
a Pennsylvanian paper salesman who owned
and operated a small-scale beet Farm
it's Dwight's ego which makes this
deleted scene so special Dwight's
password is Frodo because of course it
is and then he changes it to Gollum
because of course he does a lesser show
might have reduced Jim to a bully and
Dwight to the kicked around Patsy but
the cast and crew of The Office knew
that Dwight would never allow himself to
be reduced to such a cringing caricature
he's the volunteer sheriff and would
never show any kind of weakness around
his rival but the audience roots for
both of them because no one's really
getting hurt and Dwight and Jim meet
each other to get through their days at
Dunder Mifflin
in this deleted opening scene Dwight is
faced with the greatest dilemma of his
life when Authority is compromised who
should he obey he walks in to find his
entire desk circled in police tape
wondering what happened his first
instinct is to look at Jim who is the
obvious prankster on the one hand Dwight
believes himself to be the greatest of
all leaders evidenced most dramatically
by the time in which he was manager he
became something of a dictator
commissioning portraits of himself for
the conference room and painting his
office as black as possible to
intimidate the employees that he of
course only ever refers to as
subordinates and yet Dwight is just as
defined by his civility he never loses a
chance to play assistant to Michael and
all who fill the managerial role after
him even if it comes at the cost of his
dignity to Dwight there is no dignity
without hierarchy essentially he becomes
a robot faced with a paradox we often
saw Dwight reduced to Ridiculousness but
rarely did we ever get to see him play a
part in it himself
season 4 starts off strong and not just
because Jim and Pam finally decide to
act on their feelings that long-running
plot line plays second fiddle to the
real star of the season opener the
moment Michael hits Meredith with his
car the entire show came from that
moment poised on the edge between
horrifying and hysterical that the
office kept sharpened to a wicked point
it became a TV Legend what could ever
top Michael Scott's Thunder Mifflin
Scranton Meredith Palmer Memorial
celebrity rabies awareness Pro and Fun
Run Race for the Cure the deleted scene
of everyone visiting Meredith in the
hospital comes about as close as
anything could it's a symphony of
awkwardness A Perfect Blend of these
characters at their most Vivid Angela's
bad attitude in Kevin's blunt narcissism
are held barely in check by Michael who
of course is working overtime to
convince everyone that he is not at
fault here the scene is everything that
made these characters so weird lovable
and ultimately Unforgettable they might
not have wiped out rabies but they
cemented a place in our hearts
most film Productions shoot far more
footage than we ever see and the stuff
we do get to see on the big screen is
usually there for a pretty good reason
but when the final edits are made some
deleted scenes are sorely missed from
the movies they were cut from they might
add extra layers to the characters and
their stories provide humorous breaks
and dramatic action or even give the
audience a fascinating New Perspective
on the plot itself but these are not
those scenes No these cinematic mistakes
were better off left on The Cutting Room
floor
a dark turn
the Back to the Future movies were never
supposed to be anything but Cracker Jack
wholesome family fun so it's easy to see
why this particular scene in part 3
ended up in the trash early on in the
movie Buford tannen's gang face off with
the local martial and his young son
after disarming the Marshall Tannen
orders him to leave town he does but
Tannen shoots him in the back anyway
right in front of the boy
remember that word son
discipline while this might have been in
keeping with tannen's ruthless
detestable character it would have been
a shocking departure from the trilogy's
lighthearted tone
Ant-Man wins Big Scott Lang's desire to
turn away from crime and become a
suitable role model for his young
daughter Cassie was one of ant-man's
principal character arcs so it's no
surprise then that this scene didn't
make the cut it featured Scott's buddies
Kurt Luis and Dave indulging in a night
out at a casino consistently getting
lucky with the help of a certain
diminutive hero
[Music]
it's an entertaining sequence but given
Scott's steadfast insistence on turning
over a new Leaf it wouldn't have made a
whole lot of sense in the context of the
movie
Hadley's lost hope in James Cameron's
1986 Masterpiece aliens Sigourney
Weaver's Ellen Ripley returns to the
Moon lv-426 to make contact with a lost
human Colony accompanied by a ragtag
band of Space Marines Ripley finds the
colony deserted and half destroyed
resulting in some of the alien saga's
darkest and most unsettling scenes
nothing
not a goddamn thing
the movie's original cut however
included another scene which
single-handedly put an end to all the
tension and Terror of the abandoned
Hadley's hope here we meet the
inhabitants of the colony as they go
about their day complete with lengthy
unnecessary static shots and a walk and
talk conversation between two characters
which adds almost zero substance to the
plot
[Music]
we also meet Newt and her family before
the scene concludes with the movie's
first appearance of a Facehugger all in
all it amounts to an arduous useless
bout of exposition which would have
drained pretty much all of the suspense
from the movie's terrifying second act
judgment revoked the ending to
Terminator 2 Judgment Day is the perfect
Coda to a grim thrilling sci-fi
Adventure the audience's point of view
traverses a dark mysterious road while a
weary Sarah Connor Muses on the
ambiguity of the future before allowing
herself a brief final glimmer of hope
for Humanity's fate James Cameron's
original ending however was a little
less ambiguous we see an elderly Sarah
sitting in a park while an adult John
Connor plays with his daughter Sarah
States flatly into a tape recorder the
Judgment day has been in gone
August 29 1997 came and went
nothing much happened Michael Jackson
turned 40. she then makes a few comments
on Humanity's future which you might
recognize from the final cut fade to
black roll credits it's far too tidy and
ending and totally unsuitable for the
movie It's supposed to wrap up then
again it wouldn't have left much room
for a sequel either which may not have
been the worst thing in the world
a grievous error the showdown between
Obi-Wan Kenobi and his wheezing alien
Nemesis General Grievous was one of
Revenge of the sith's most entertaining
sequences according to a discarded
animatic for the scene however the fight
almost ended in the most ridiculous way
possible the scene would have played out
largely the same right up to the moment
that Kenobi manages to partially pry
open Grievous protective chest plate
rather than getting cold cocked and
nearly falling to his death Kenobi would
have finished Grievous off by tearing
out his heart with his bare hands
casually tossing it aside and Blasting
it with his sidearm somehow managing to
be both way too dark and cartoonish at
the same time the very fact that this
scene was cut from the movie is
quantifiable proof that George Lucas is
sometimes capable of discarding bad
ideas
not quite getting out at the climax of
Jordan Peel's Masterpiece get out
protagonist Chris Washington finally
escapes the grip of the nefarious
Armitage family as he barely restrains
himself from strangling Rose his
ex-girlfriend and pursuer a police car
arrives knowing nobody could possibly
believe his story Chris prepares to be
arrested or worse but it's a fake out
the car is driven by Chris's TSA buddy
Rod who helps Chris make good his Escape
in the movie's original ending however
it really is the police who arrive and
Chris is promptly arrested and taken to
jail
I stopped it you know
I stopped although it might have made
for a more realistic conclusion to the
plot Peel's decision to give the
beleaguered Chris a happy ending seems
like it was for the best
Clerk's last shot
Kevin Smith's 1994 debut feature is a
largely plot free film which found most
of its comedic mileage in the
reference-laden dialogue of its slacker
leads it's a slight sardonic work in
which almost nothing happens which would
have made its alternate ending not only
shocking but completely inappropriate in
the original ending Dante is closing up
the store after Randall leaves a man
approaches the counter and Dante informs
him that they're closed only to be shot
dead on the spot as the man cleans out
the register the movie ends with a
close-up on Dante's lifeless body Smith
claimed that he shot this ending simply
because he had no idea how to end the
movie but fortunately star Brian
O'Halloran who hated the sequence was
able to convince him to cut it thank
goodness or the film might not have
become the cult classic it is today
[Music]